hey guys my name is David sandwich and
I'm the founder of white watches today
I'm going to teach you how to set up
your original collection timepiece in
this video you'll learn how to attach
the strap to the watch how to set date
and time and just in case you need to
know how to switch out the buckle with
everyday kitchen utensils so let's get
started so when you receive a new
original collection timepiece you're
going to get in a nice box like this the
little short strap goes on the top and
you want to get the pin to connect into
the back and push the little spring pin
till you hear it click once it clicks
you can take the longest side and do the
same thing on the bottom it's quite a
simple process but sometimes it is a
little bit stiff and if you find it a
bit tricky just squeeze the sides of the
leather strap and it should click in a
lot simpler
to adjust the date and time simply
pushing the crown and then click it out
once when you click it out once it's
going to allow you to change the date
and when you're happy with the date
click it out once more so 2 in total and
you should be able to adjust the time to
your current location when you're happy
push the crown back in completely and
your watch is ready to go
chances are you're never going to have
to do this step but in case you need to
simply grab a kitchen knife
flip the strap upside down and slide the
knife in between the buckle and the
leather strap
rotate it as such until it pops open and
you should be able to pull the spring
out and the tongue as well if you need
to put it back make sure you put the
tongue in first followed by the spring
pin and then slide the buckle in similar
to the leather strap on the watch and
use your fingernails to click the spring
pin into the buckle and till you hear a
click
once you've hit the head they click
that's all there is to it